- Yeah, it's not working.
I should be Justin Timberlake.
Doug looks like Hilary Clinton.
- Boy band!
- Today, we are recreating iconic boy band
album covers.
NSYNC, Backstreet Boys,
and now One Direction.
- All of these boy bands have five people,
but we only have four Try Guys.
- Ned is bringing in his
college friend, Doug.
- As long as he knows that I'm the star
and he's not expecting
to be the Timberlake,
because, obviously, I'm the Timberlake.
- I love when we get
an outside personality
in Try Guys videos because you never know
what happens when a fifth
Try Guy is added to the mix.
(electronic music)
- Everybody meet Doug.
Hey!
- [Group] Hey! A dog?
- This is the best day ever.
I love dogs so much.
- As long as I get to be JT,
I'm going to be fine with this.
- Yeah, he's gotta be the
Justin Timberlake of the group.
- That's not okay.
I'm Keith of the Try Guys,
aka Justin Timberlake of NSYNC.
He's falling asleep.
- [Ned] Keith, he can hear you.
- I've heard a lot about your from Ned,
and I'm really, really excited
to have you on the shoot, so.
- [Eugene] Are you worried
that he's going to be
the new small one?
- I'm the cute, furry small one
and now we've got another
cute, furry small one.
Why do we need Doug?
It just doesn't make sense to me.
- You know, when your college friends
meet your Try Guy friends,
you're kind of worried that
everyone's gonna get along,
but it seems like everyone's
getting along great.
Hey, Doug. Hi!
(kisses)
- [Ned] Okay, Doug.
- [Eugene] You ready to do this, Doug?
He's even got the sexy eyes down.
Look at that sexy gaze.
There are so many soul
patches and butt cuts
on this album cover, it
makes me kind of angry.
- What's a butt cut?
- What Keith has on his head.
- Oh!
- I haven't looked at it yet
because I don't wanna look at it.
- You look like an evil scientist.
- My wife said I looked Italian.
- These white clothes are pretty awesome.
- [Zach] These are pretty pimp!
I feel like people don't
have the confidence
to rock this all white on
an album cover anymore.
- Here's the thing, Doug.
If you're gonna be the
leader, you have to stand up.
- [Zach] Doug is being
really hard to work with.
I don't really wanna talk about it.
Doug is repeatedly undercutting me,
taking all of the cutest
members of the band
and making me the worst one
that no one wants to be.
- Honestly, Doug is the best
person I've ever worked with.
It's great to strive for
excellence next to an expert.
- [Zach] Okay, Doug.
So, we just did The Backstreet
Boys' Millennium album cover.
Now, it's time to move
onto our favorite band--
- [Group] NSYNC!
- And obviously since you
got to be the leader of that,
and you did a terrible job,
it's my turn now to be--
(record stops)
Joey Fat One?
(hip-hop music)
- He's looking at us real weird.
I just want to say, Doug,
that I've noticed that you've
pushed me further to the
outside in this photo.
I don't appreciate it.
- Yeah, this is not working.
- [Keith] It's not classic Justin.
No, it's not for eating.
- Ah, Ramen hair.
- Also, I checked the reference photo.
My guy doesn't even have his arms up.
We all wanted to be NSYNC because we all
wanted to be Justin.
Now, look at this guy.
- I loved NSYNC when I was a kid.
I watched, like, a documentary on NSYNC
on the Disney Channel.
- [Ned] Boy bands were for girls
and as guys we were
supposed to not like them.
My sister got the Dance Dance Groove DVD
and I tried to learn this dance.
It is the hardest fucking
thing I've ever done.
- Who's the most beautiful,
beautiful Buzzfeed member ever?
- You know, there was some
tension there earlier,
but I think Keith and Doug
are really appreciating
each other professionally.
- Doug, can I talk to you for a second?
Look, I know you and I have
had our differences today,
but this last photo shoot, I
think, it's really important
that everyone just end the day happy.
What do you say we just,
for this last shoot,
bury the hatchet and let all of us choose
our own One Direction member?
Thanks, Doug.
- I need to become stylishly hairy.
- Alright.
- Oh, is this what his hair looks like?
Here we are.
- [Group] Hey!
- One Direction!
- Doug, thanks again for letting us pick
our members this time.
I think it's a nice way to end.
Guys, really, One Direction is the NSYNC
and Backstreet Boys of
the young generation.
- [Eugene] Backstreet Boys
and NSYNC, there's always,
kind of, like a few not-so-cute members,
but across the board,
One Direction is pretty good-looking.
- [Zach] Everyone is
cute in One Direction.
- [Eugene] The thing
about this album cover,
it almost looks like
just an Instagram photo.
- Yeah, it kind looks like a photo booth.
- Yeah.
- Just five bros hanging out.
- It probably took them five hours to do,
just like this one.
- Doug, you're the
expert and we trust you.
What should we do for this picture?
- Get Zen, man.
- Alright, let's do it.
- Yeah, holding those poses,
without moving was really, really hard.
- [Ned] It was really touch
introducing my old friend, Doug,
to the Try Guys,
but I think everyone
bonded together at the end.
You know, Doug does that.
He brings people together.
- If I'm going to share being
the small, cute hairy one
with anyone, I'm glad it as Doug.
- [Keith] Although we weren't
friends in the beginning,
now we're totally best friends forever.
I'm just really glad for
the opportunity we had
to share with him.
It's been a pretty good day
- Well, thank you so much for
showing us your ways, Doug.
- I know we had our
differences throughout the day,
but I think we all grew
closer because of it.
- And now, we're ready to
offer you a permanent position
with The Try Guys.
- What do you say, pal?
- [Group] Dang!
- Eh, we don't need him.
- You know, guys, I have
a confession to make.
He's not actually my college roommate.
He's just a dog.
- Yeah, I know.
- [Group] We knew that the whole time.
- It was so obvious.